[Música]
mi mayor intención en la jurisdicción
especial para la paz en donde estoy es
poder trabajar todos los días y
contribuir para que lo que nos pasó a
nosotros como pueblo no le pase a ningún
pueblo y nos siga pasando porque sé que
pasa en muchas partes del país
[Música]
espero que la ceremonia de hoy sea una
oportunidad para que la gente piense en
lo preciosa que es la paz y lo
importante que son los derechos que
tenemos
y las generaciones más jóvenes reconocen
este problema están conectando los
puntos cuando hablamos de conservación
ambiental
estamos hablando de conservación humana
y están muy preocupados por los jóvenes
de todo el mundo hay un alto grado de
ansiedad y miedo sobre lo que depara el
futuro pero también se tiene que
reconocer que tienen poder y que cuando
nos unimos como comunidad y amplificamos
nuestra voz podemos cambiar el mundo
[Música]
la música a menudo nos permite sentir lo
que aún no somos capaces de expresar con
palabras la música es un faro la música
puede empujar nos en la dirección en la
que tenemos que ir antes de darnos
cuenta de que tenemos que ir allí
y entonces veo la música a la vanguardia
de las luchas y especialmente de
aquellas que reflejan específicamente la
justicia la libertad y el fin de la
violencia sin la música no estaríamos
donde estamos
faisal y la decisión de la histórica
loya jirga acaba con las excusas para
comenzar con las negociaciones internas
en afganistán y dios lo quiera estamos
al borde de iniciar las conversaciones
de paz el gobierno está comprometido a
implementar el consejo de los miembros
de la amenaza dio tico
una de las características de la
protectora una de las características de
la prelatura de sanfélix es la
solidaridad que dice que va y viene es
de doble mano la solidaridad no nos dan
y damos también
[Música]
no hay dudas y claro es obvio que dada
la naturaleza de nuestra lucha y su
larga duración existe la desconfianza
pero este nuevo tiempo ha llegado para
tener fe y no tengo dudas que si todos
trabajamos juntos para implementar lo
que los primeros ministros han propuesto
y para implementar todos los detalles la
desconfianza terminará y ahora que vamos
a un nuevo siglo vamos a dejar nuestro
pasado atrás y vamos a destinar todas
las energías para construir una nueva
sociedad con total y absoluto respeto
por la identidad de las dos partes de
nuestro pueblo gracias
[Música]